faire du profit sur le dos de l'écologie
c'est en gros ce que reproche
l'organisation les amis de la terre à la
france pour reprendre leur terme exact
la france est accusée d'amorcer une
bombe climatique au mozambique et plus
précisément le groupe français total qui
développe un méga projet d'exploitation
de gaz naturel
les pouvoirs publics français se soient
activés depuis plusieurs années pour que
les industriels du gaz et leurs
banquiers profitent de l'eldorado gazier
à 60 milliards de dollars au mozambique
contribuant ainsi à enfoncer le pays
dans la dépendance aux énergies fossiles
le nom du rapport est plutôt explicite
de l'eldorado gazier au chaos quand la
france poussent le mozambique dans le
piège du gaz
prenons le temps de faire un peu de
géographie vous le voyez sur cette carte
le mozambique a découvert au début des
années 2010 de vastes réserves sous
marines au large de ses côtes nord dans
l'océan indien
estimé à 5000 milliards de mètres cubes
elles doivent transformer un des pays
les plus pauvres de la planète en un
exportateur de gaz naturel liquéfié de
tout premier plan
emmanuel macron n'a pas manqué de le
rappeler en janvier dernier le
mozambique découvre qu'il a des
formidable gisement dans ses eaux
territoriales
il est en train de les exploiter
d'ailleurs avec parfois des opérateurs
français la difficulté qu'on aura
collectivement c'est d'expliquer à des
pays pauvres qui découvrent des
gisements
comment il va falloir se passer de ces
hydrocarbures
il va falloir trouver des compensations
dans l'économie internationale pour les
aider à en sortir et les rendre moins
dépendant de cela elles des paroles qui
ne vont pas empêcher les lobbys
industriels de mettre la pression au
gouvernement français pour que ces
ressources fossiles soit exploité à leur
profit au détriment de l'environnement
et de l'humain oui car exploiter ces
gisements revient à l'équivalent de ses
torts d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de la france voilà pour le volet
écologique pas son volet guérilla ces
fameuses réserves de gaz sont situées
dans la province mozambicaine du cabo
delgado théâtre depuis deux ans et demi
d'une insurrection islamiste qui a fait
plus de 1100 morts
conséquence la population civile est
prise en otage entre les remous
politiques internes et l'installation de
multinationales qui déplace des familles
entières de pêcheurs et d'agriculteurs
et pour fini
on ajoute à ça que le littoral abrite
une incroyable biodiversité en danger à
cause de ces projets gaziers
les amis de la terre appellent le
gouvernement français à mettre un point
d'arrêt à la diplomatie du chaos au
service des industriels des énergies
fossiles et de l'armement en commençant
par cesser de leur octroyer des aides
publiques à l'exportation
au vu de la gravité des violations des
droits humains des risques
environnementaux et climatiques
il somme les entreprises françaises
impliquées banques privées comme crédit
agricole et société générale
industrielle de l'énergie comme total de
se retirer des projets gaziers au large
du mozambique et de renoncer à tout
développement de nouveaux projets pour
revenir sur un dernier chiffre 60
milliards de dollars c'est
l'investissement estimé dans cette
région par l'industrie fossile soit
quatre fois le pib du mozambique en 2019
des chiffres qui ne font pas reculer les
amis de la terre violations des droits
humains corruption destruction des
écosystèmes
le message est passé reste à savoir s'il
sera entendu ou si une fois de plus
l'écologie humaine et environnementale
sera sacrifié sur l'autel du profit